hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome dis Orion this is a game
where you play as a dinosaur if that
wasn't obvious who
ah why can't I be a Tyranno I want to be
a feathery Tyranno yeah so dinosaurs
have changed from our childhoods they
basically now we know that a lot of them
were already starting to have feathers
on them so when you got a de kado Dakota
Raptor of course that's different
because there's a lot of different
dinosaur eras like the dinosaurs that we
found exist over a period of millions
and millions of years it's all very
complicated
there's probably here's a big timeline
of dinosaurs and all their history and
whatever have you
there goes hope you caught it positive
you didn't either way we're gonna play a
Dakota Raptor I'm all be a Rando I don't
know what I am but I'm a Dakota Raptor
oh look at me squiggle okay never mind I
stop squiggle blending as soon as I call
the times do it ooh there we go oh I'm a
Dakota Raptor I'm a little baby mama hey
mom mom where you going mom
please leave me I'm so scared
is that my brother and or sister I don't
know we are but alike I like the swishy
of my tail I got nice tail look at his
tail Dakota Raptors are not good parents
they will tolerate you as a hatchling
but once you become a juvenile they will
start to see you as food I don't know if
you knew that how do you go back in time
and get to the point where their mothers
eat their children Bava
tolerate me shall be some affection by
tolerating my presence the red bar
represents your health if when this is
empty you will die health can be lost
from injury or extreme thirst or hunger
okay so I'm a Dakota Raptor blah blah I
love you I made you a macaroni art she
stopped do you like it do you approve do
you tolerate it oh you're gonna hang it
on the tree
mama Oh mom why are you pushing me
don't push me out of camp mama please I
don't want to go oh no you're pushing me
out of the nest baba mama am I about to
kick
[Laughter]
whoa all right fine
be that as it may I got a forge for
myself and find my own desk in the out
here cuz I'm a Dakota Raptor and I am
gonna survive on my own I don't need my
mama I'm going out into the wild
to survive this is cool though the big
expansive Plains kind of like any old
big expansive plains you would find if
you went out into the actual real world
can't jump maybe not yet pretty tasty
air we got here
left-click performs a basic attack and
when in combat you must break the skin
to deal proper damage to an animal can
lead you to attack the same place for
best effect aiming for the throat will
result in a faster kill there's a lot
for a baby to learn eat a sniff the air
smooth I'm Stefan I'm snoring up a storm
I don't see any scent particles hmm I go
farther forth
let me snore over this way snore no it's
north yeah it's Norfolk oh I love the
way it runs whoo they'll never catch me
I'm runnin serpentine style Oh hit a
tree but that's ok I'm sniffs Norv ooh
ooh yeah yeah gets North gets North get
numbed
where'd you go Oh would you go sniffing
sniffing there you wait no oh you're
here someone whoa I saw you I caught a
glimpse oh I'm on you I'm on you oh I'm
out of energy apparently oh I shouldn't
have been serpentining so much I'm gonna
get you think you got away from me huh
I got a good snore fer right here I mean
to sneak up on stealth like sprint after
did I get him oh I got him I didn't get
him oh I stopped him real good
mom are you proud of me I'm gonna make
you an art from bones um oh [ __ ] dude is
that my tongue oh I got me
mama you're proud of me got me where'd
it go oh it still here still got it mmm
mama gonna be proud of me maybe I'll
finally be as good as my brother
probably not only do doodly-doo
disappoint a family Ducks are sad
alright anyway I get back in there I
don't know what's with the green bar
going up and up and up like that but I
gotta find me my mama oh never mind got
a load first mama mama no you're not
mama get out of here get out of my
mama's house Oh No I've lost mama mama
no I'm fine
well I'm gonna take this food with me
wherever I go and maybe I'm gonna find
myself a mate even though I'm too young
to think about those kind of things
I gotta grow up fast here out in the
wilds of the the saurian region also
gotta cool down for a bit oh I can't
jump I jumped super-good we use that to
get away from predators as soon as they
come after me because I'm sure that
without my mama I'm gonna be all trapped
and alone and scared in the middle of
the woods and everybody's gonna try to
eat me hope someone comes to my rescue
like a parental figure who wasn't there
for me okay I gotta find me some water
cuz this sun's going down I gotta find a
camp or something I water oh I'm sure
there's no giant dinosaurian crocodiles
over there hmm
either way down the food there's some
water I suppose the other bar on the
green must have been like my overfill
meter I ate enough that it you know was
fine go log lug okay well now I'm
thirsted you take a little dip for a
bath oh that's good
that's nice oh I'm so happy except for
remembering everybody that left me
behind but that's okay
gettin dark skin dork ooh getting real
weird because the colors are going all
pastel on me oh good golly frame rate
took a hint all right that's a little
better the ominous music is still there
but I don't know what else to do about
that so we just gotta carry on as if
nothing's a problem
the middle of the night I'm still gonna
need food and if you can see I got an A
Joe meter up there so I need to aid you
up need to grow up fast there's a big
sniffer over there that sound that's
probably not good as a big sniffs
knocker what's what's snarfing so much
scent over there did a pile of poop or
something there not be a pot whoa hi
hello friend you look mean I'm gonna
back away back away very slowly
i'ma back away from you you're one of my
brothers or sisters or cousins I don't
want to know you if you might think of
me as food and that ain't cool bro that
ain't cool so this is gonna be a period
of going sniffin agent and growing
I hope there's some growing associated
with that I don't want to be small
forever as a Dakota rapper you can only
get so big man it's hard to get my my
energy oh we can oh I can get a little
nap I slept swarmed that was probably
bad oh it's morning oh look at me look
at me I figured out how to sleep alone
without my mama without the warm comfort
ah
what a world what a wonderful world this
is all right it's okay I'm gonna go in
my angsty phase you Inc you okay I need
some food where can I find me some
breakfast sniffs Norv it's Nam from
maybe I could try to eat this Lee oh
[ __ ]
this is Norbert where to go oh I see
where'd you go give me another little
scent give me a fart of fear fart fear
me give me a little fart fear
come on something anything spit in my
direction I got away son of a [ __ ] off
to find another one oh this is actually
really cool I'm like totally tuned in
I'm real dinosaur I'm channeling my you
oh oh that was as a leaf leaf I'm
hallucinating I'm so hungry but this
cool I'm just like it's very simple
objectives just survive that's kinda
nice you don't have to worry about like
a crafting system or anything like that
you're just a dino and a world full of
dinos and they could probably kill you
dad
very much so if I encounter a t-rex I'm
gonna be full looked wait
hello I see you okay losing sight of you
this time okay he's going away yeah I
see okay he stopped right there so if I
just he's moving he's in that brush
somewhere in the brush here come on no
Frick come on oh wait there's that get
him was that not him
oh that had to be him mmm Frank
I should just gunned it for him as soon
as I saw him sneaking is for losers why
is there a sniff here then this is what
he left behind damn god they move quick
all right it's getting dire I gotta get
food in me or else I am going to die and
that's no good no bueno no bueno I can't
go to sleep with it on an empty stomach
I have to find food tonight rest when I
can take a little city sit Hey let's pop
a squat come on pop a little squat Oh
lizard dead ahead okay I'm gonna get you
you you can't see me in the brush can
you sniff sniff oh yeah I kind of lock
on you get you get you okay get up you
know get get up get up
oh don't do that don't get over here
position by jumping you and you where'd
you go where'd you go you son of a [ __ ]
I bid on your face I bid on you we did
it oh I did it
Frick god dammit never get another
opportunity like that dammit I'm in like
the heavy brush area so of course I'm
not gonna get anything well I might as
well just run and chomp randomly
hopefully I'll get one hopefully one
will jump into my mouth I think we're
all realizing I'm not a very good
dinosaur your eyes open everybody keep
your eyes peeled this is where we
separate the weak from the strong and I
am this row
hey mama you're not mama
I'd recognize me you're not mama you
ignored me like mama did nothing that
not not anyway I need food bad it's
getting bad isn't bad if I don't get
this next one I might be dead I might be
dead whoo hello who are you
what are you doing don't even think
about it [ __ ] you up you know I'm
desperate enough okay excuse you how did
you get me in one boot freak [ __ ] you
ain't gonna go down like that ain't
gonna be like that and then gonna be
like that at all
son of a dick so I'm not too far off
from where I was so lesson learned don't
try to kill your fellow Volusia Reuters
Dakota repeaters lesson to hunt good or
don't hunt stupidly right I'm like a
shadow in the night I'm like a shadow in
the middle of the day I'm just gonna hop
from brush to brush I'm gonna sniff real
hard on my snuffer and then I'm gonna
find me a goddamn freaking lizard and
I'm gonna eat it well oh I found you I
found you where where where where were
you did a patter pitter patter pitter
patter use my ears use my significant
hunting ears their patter I see
I don't hear the pitter-patter did I get
it no damn I lost it how did they just
disappear like that just disappear like
that
I think this thick shrubbery is throwing
me off store it off my hunter senses I'm
actually a good hunter but just you know
in these circumstances is just a little
difficult I could do it in the open
plains I don't know why I came over here
probably just because I wanted to
explore or something or see you the rest
of the world or try to get away from
home on an don't find myself in the wild
getting more open over here it's good oh
there there there there there there
there there there your mind your mind
your mind come on you oh your mind nope
I'm not gonna lose you again
where'd you go that is impossible
he he was in this bush you were in this
bush you were in the bush I didn't turn
away my eyes locked on you oh the Freak
what is with that I swear I've been on
these things over and over again oh it's
down to the wire oh it is down to the
wire
I don't get it why did why was I able to
get the one like the first one I got was
so easy to get what are you eating what
are you eating what are you eating can I
eat it I'm creating a goddamn bush oh
you barbarian oh you disgust me
I'm gonna go find me some meat obviously
I can because I can't even do that right
maybe I shouldn't have run away from
home oh boy yeesh I've got no food left
in me none at all
not at all what is this this is a swamp
snow is this snow what is sand why is
there sand here that's weird but okay oh
now I'm gonna die I'm a disappointment
Mambo's right oh no I wonder no my
health is going down yeah I'm starving
and now my health is going down so I've
just got a run it's got a run hope
something falls inside my face come on
there's got to be one
lizard one little lizard that wants to
sacrifice itself work what am I looking
over there wait oh oh oh don't lag there
oh oh oh ah did I get you know I saw
that though for you for you for you I
know you're in there I know you were
just there where did you go how do you
do that what the [ __ ] you just vanish oh
my god oh wait no there you're oh oh oh
I want you please just you know you want
to be eaten okay I'm gonna rest up a
second
so my head goes where come on over there
oh yes no yes no was that it was that it
was that it was that it yes and I can
advance to the next growth stage I don't
have any water so let me go find some
water first why was that so difficult
cuz I didn't pay attention I don't know
if it said it in the tutorial but the
head points towards the animals so when
you're running like this Dino is smarter
than me am with my human eyes ah that
makes so much more sense I gave to get
some water before I do the the
transition thing hey you know what I'm
gonna go for it what's the worst that
could happen I'm gonna grow I'm gonna be
a big Dino oh look at me look at me I'm
so mature the Kota Raptor can take down
larger prey with Raptor prey restraint
jump
on to an animal to initiate our PR once
mounted flap to maintain your balance by
clicking right mouse button and damage
your prey with left mouse button oh
let's try that
who are you can I kill you and I see
something over there who I can zoom out
a bit that's nice
give me a little freedom to work with oh
you fool thing is so lethal ah come on
okay well anyway so I'm into the next
growth stage this is actually a really
cool game I like this alive there's
there's a lot of potential it's in early
access obviously like every game these
days but this one's cool because it's so
simplistic like it's narrowly defined in
you are a dino try to survive try to be
a Dino this is what a Dino do they kill
and eat try that and I'm not very good
at it right now but I kind of survived
except for attacking those other Dakota
Raptors or whatever they were so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see more of this let me know
down the comments below I kind of want
to see what the other grouse days is
like and I kind of want to see what a
freaking tiny Rhino is gonna do for me
when I'm able to do that so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]